now then the final question and again
it's all about the language isn't it
Part C find the probability that Pat
eventually wins eventually we don't
usually see words like that in questions
like this eventually is there some kind
of area of mathematics that we know
about when you know you're adding
numbers together and you can't say the
first or the second or the third or the
fourth eventually means you do all of
them have you ever had any experience
with topics that help us add up a long
series of items that have to see the
sequences right too much of a giveaway
so I need to form the series here to
work out the probability of Pat
eventually winning Pat eventually wins
this is the probability of him winning
on the first or the second or the third
or the fourth or any of those times that
he actually rolls the dice does this
make sense
now I've already started to form this
series haven't I've got these two here
what am I going to put here I'm actually
going to write it like so this is the
first in a second now what would happen
I don't really want to keep on drawing
the rest of the probability train I
think I can work it out because of the
pattern established what will have to
happen for him to win not only this
first or second but on his third roll
will have to happen after for example
Chad losing if if I wanted to win on his
not his second but his third roll what
happens here Pat will have to lose again
then Chad will have to lose again and
then finally Pat wins that's his third
attempt right so here's those two losses
but I want to do them a couple more
times right so instead of that squared
I'm gonna have that to the power of four
right it's an even number because it has
two channeis losing then Pat has two
sorry
past lose then Chad us losing then it
comes back to here and then finally it
ends on a one out of 36 what does that
represent
well the one out of 36 always represents
the actual completion of the game he
wins right but this will keep on going
forever
okay now whoopsie-daisy now this is a
series that gets smaller and each term
successfully gets smaller and smaller
and smaller and it gets small fast
enough to have what's it called when
this whole thing approaches something it
has a limiting some right what is the
formula for limiting some it's a really
simple one hopefully you remember it
it's a fraction yeah a what's it what's
a what's a it's this guy here I'm just
gonna write that and then I think I
heard you say that denominator has one
minus R one minus mmm
what's R in this case yeah you got to do
it twice don't you and then you can see
it goes twice the next one will be 35 on
36 to the six so this looks a little
gross there you go can you give me a
fraction can you work that out you got
there well okay so I think you should
and your calculator can make mincemeat
of this awkward looking for actually you
should get 36 on 71 now I'm gonna ask
the question one more time can someone
give that to me as a decimal zero point
zero point five can you give me a few
more zero for two - da da da okay great
so I want us to do two things here
number one I want to notice what makes
this question curly why is this in the
HSC well one of the it sounds terrible
but one of the great things that you can
finally do with the HSC is take all this
knowledge you develop in a whole bunch
of different places like say probability
and series and sequences and now that at
this final point we can say are you
meant to know all of this we can
actually combine it in interesting ways
right I know that makes it harder but it
also makes it more interesting you learn
something that's the first thing the
second thing is all the way through I've
been trying to get you the sense check
here right it turns out fractions like
this and
this are pretty awful at doing sense
checks when it comes to probability but
if you put them into a percentage or a
decimal they'll be easier to read this
is just above half isn't it's just above
half so it's Pat has better than even
odds but it's very close to even why
does he have slightly better than even
odds he starts first so he gets a slight
leg up into the situation right but then
you should expect it to go to Awards
half why would you expect it to go to
was half patent Chadd right what must
they do to win they must roll two sixes
in other words they have to do the same
thing to win right winning means the
same thing for both of them they've got
to achieve the same goal so you'd expect
both the probabilities to get quite
close to each other because they have to
do the same thing to win does that make
sense whereas if we skewed the game one
way or another if there was a way to die
or something like that that's when it
would change okay so probability trees
you kind of I mean to create this part
here which is sort of what the real
question is about it's pretty difficult
to try and stream this together without
having at least a simple diagram to
understand where those probabilities
come from so that's why they can be
useful okay